[Music]
my dad had these stack of Cosby records
and Steve Martin records there you go
and I used to a spiral notebook and I
would write down what joke was funny and
why and why oh dude I was like trying to
pull him apart oh yeah CU I just want to
know why cuz I was so mesmerized by
someone makes laugh but it seemed like
everybody was um kind of okay with
getting poked and it like that was kind
of the thing right like they were the
profits of your time they can say what
they want yeah and now it seems to have
shifted where you can't you can't except
I was talking to somebody the other day
and tell me if I'm crazy I think in a
hundred years the story that will be
written on this weird little snapshot of
History will include Rogan and Chappelle
as the guys that broke it that made I'm
going to keep saying this and maybe
that's crazy but I feel like the only
the last great voice is a comedian
that's it I feel like this allow you
don't want to look back on your your
Instagram or you're whatever you're
posting from like a year ago or two
years ago and cringe at it and you go oh
I can't believe I posted that right
right with with whatever the whatever it
is whatever the social issue was you how
it's embarrassing everybody's like oh
must be tough being a comedian when it's
you can be canceled it for everything
I'm like no I feel like it's actually
very it's easier because in in Carlin
and Eddie Murphy the line to like be
inappropriate was so right yeah you had
to say something so outlandish that
people like and now all you have to be
is like and the line is right the line
is right here and it moves yeah so you
can just like and it's like ah and it
makes it it makes because the what
comedy is is saying the quiet part out
loud that's it the thing that most
people are thinking and now you're
supposed to be quiet about everything
right so and and I I'd say to my live
shows like my live show is just a group
text with your buddies out loud I would
say if Joe Rogan and Dave Chappelle
maybe saved it it it is as and I used
use them as as examples of is bold in
other people that now there's a lot
there's a yeah people start went to look
and say is somebody that big gonna get
taken down and they didn't and suddenly
well it's uni yeah it's Unique in a way
where Joe Rogan if Spotify said we're
out he could all right well I'll go to
Apple exct yeah then you have more
they're above the I don't need to get
PID I'm above that yeah it makes you
more honest it makes you a minimum more
honest right so you go I need to sell
tickets they go I don't need to sell I
can never I don't never have to work
again exactly I'm just interested in the
truth there you go that's it that's what
that's what Joe I think is great as as
an audience member I go I may not go
with you but I know that's what your
intent is it's not to satisfy this and
you could disagree or you could agree or
disagree but Joe Rogan says yo the
homelessness in La is out of hand right
and when the the governor says we really
making a lot of improvements you're like
I'm driving around it's not no it's not
it's not and now we have my brother
lives out there and he has kids and
there it's it's unsafe and it's unsafe
for every like that's not true cuz the
governor's office could call the local
affiliate and say you're going to we
need this story we're going to run the
story we have a new initiative or we
have and you and that's when you look
around and go no yeah and the last time
I I saw you play I it was you were
saying things about parenting you're
saying things about going to Sunday
school that everyone thinks and everyone
knows and it's it's but it's that same
it's not Los Angeles but it's that same
like everyone's like yeah that's that's
I mean that's I started in comedy
I was um as my dad's a pastor Okay and
like in in church and you would
see maybe like uh as a pastor's kid
behind the curtain a little bit my dad
was too yeah so you so you go Shea
sausage is made a little bit and then
you see the Sunday morning product and
from a young age I
go exactly and not not not in in a anti-
Christian way but I just go you see the
Gap yeah my bedroom backed up to my
Dad's closet and he would pull that
corded phone in there when there was
like stuff was going down oh yeah and it
backed up against where I slept and so I
could just listen quietly and then I
would show up on Sundays and I'd see the
guy in the suit or the woman in the nice
dress and I'd say Ah that's there's
something else going on here and I just
remember that that that messed me up for
a long time or the guy in that used to
be in a suit and now he doesn't work
there anymore and you're like exactly
you're like and God called him to a
new he he's pursuing other opportunities
and and some May and he was called away
and by called away we don't you gotta
leave right now and as a guy that was
performing in churches a bunch and and
it's not
necessarily the the behavior is people
go I'm a human I don't but it's but you
said yeah subconsciously or not that you
were this guy if Dave Ramsey was like a
billion dollars in debt he had a bunch
of credit cards yeah yeah yeah do we
care about credit card at no but you
said you said not to and that's what
that's what everybody has a hard time
stomaching which which Fair very fair
yeah yeah so I think there's just
something about telling the truth but
that's where I think ComEd comedy is so
great is it it you guys just walk out
into the middle of that Gap and you're
like here we are right what are you are
we really doing this and what's
beautiful about the art form that I'm
more passionate about now than I ever
have is like some people would say how
come that comedian gets to I remember
making jokes like in the Christian
subculture and that like the some of the
more or you know christian celebrities
if that's even a word we're like how
come he gets to say all that and it's
how come he gets to go up there and just
let it rip yeah and and I and I always
said it's actually the opposite we can
only say what
you already think and if I said like I
like what's the deal with all the the
all the German population in Franklin
you'd be like what are you talking about
what that does it's not a truth right
it's so doesn't it doesn't go or spread
or it actually falls dormant yeah if a
if you makes a joke and everybody goes
oh my
goodness that's the truest thing I've
ever seen that's what you make it go not
the comedian okay comedian doesn't has
no power you're just comedian just
shines lights on things that already
exist and sometimes we shine lights and
people goes no it's not in there okay
and like and then you go oh yeah good to
know I remember the first open my kite
this somebody in college said you should
try standup comedy it's the first time I
ever the idea of I mean I loved comedy
loved watching it obviously I was more
like uh uh Cat Williams Bruce Bruce one
one one kind of generation behind that
but I I was mesmerized by same thing and
the guy goes you should try stand up
comedy and and I and that day I
started a Word document on my computer
about funny things kind of similar to
you why
interacting with this idea M and then it
took me about four and a half years to
build up the courage and I went into the
open mic and I said I want to I went to
the guy after and I go I want to I want
to do it I want to do it and he goes all
right and he goes he looked at his book
and he goes uh June 23rd is 2009 June
23rd and that was like a month from and
I I mean didn't sleep oh yeah didn't eat
just walking around neighborhood like oh
yeah just trying to it's I mean there's
30 people in there 40 maybe and and I
remember throwing up in the green room
before the show was the Laughing Skull
Lounge in Atlanta Georgia and the guy
older more seasoned veteran came in and
he goes listen man he goes your first
time I go yeah he goes well they can't
kill you and they can't put you in
jail and that was
oddly I go huh what am I what what that
means the only barrier is you and what
were you scared of right it seems not
sleeping not eating sweating for and I
wanted to do it four years prior to that
and couldn't get up the courage to go
sign up so what was what was the fear
the worst case scenario is you got to
move back home yeah and your parents
will love you and and you'll get back on
your Fe you're like and you go oh it
becomes a more risk to stay at your job
than
so the
fear that fear overcame this fear the
fear of staying in my job and then I'm
all of a sudden I'm too late and I can't
go pursue it and knowing that one time
you did it how how you how alive
yourself the yeah if you yeah I mean but
dude I you remember like in asking girls
to prom oh yeah yeah terrifying but but
and then what's the worst but what is
the wor yeah what is the worst the I but
it happened it happened the dude I'll
look whoever in the camera in the eye
and say the worst possible things that
you could possibly imagine happening to
you has happened to
me and we're laughing about it the worst
possible thing that I could ever imagine
happen outside of death yeah right
happened to me yes and now you
go well are playing with house money now
that's it that's it that's it or what
and it's always someone on the other
side of it that's like oh I'm playing
with house money you're playing with
house money yeah I mean I was in rehab
in 2019 and I go we were putting our
lives back together everybody was in
there and I go we're about to get out of
there and I go guys more bad stuff is
going to happen to us mhm right death
parents uh all of it disease losses of
job like bad like look at the country
more bad stuff is coming so to rectify
this current situation okay
but put a position yourself to whatever
whatever horrible things be like all
right cool because I've been there yeah
and you look at you look sometimes you
look at grandparents they act like they
don't care or they don't they've been
there yeah dude they go all there people
my granddad and be like hey Dad Granddad
this thing's happening just real slow he
fought Nazis he's like we're probably
not that your situation isn't important
it is but you're good go you're good
well you're and it's very slow like back
and and you're like well how can you
have this perspective cuz they've been
through it yeah that's right and you
look at a a kid that we all were at one
time and you go hey I my bike has a flat
tire this is the worst It's the End of
Time It's the End of Time when I asked
that girl to prom she said no I got
rejected online too you did yeah dude
you look at the camera listen I was kind
of a cool kid yeah dude why don't I
don't understand I went to her house I
took my shirt in dude went to house I
didn't went to her house front door
front door knocked on the door she told
me to know in person so did mine so did
mine I had a couple I walked out and I
didn't I couldn't believe it you didn't
know even know how to turn on the
ignition on in your car it never
occurred to me that that could happen
it's not funny it is funny oh super now
but at the time well I I was it was
listless I I just
I you were like I'm going to have to
transfer schools that's what I thought
I'm just going to go out in the parking
lot set myself on fire you know what I
mean I have to make another rage against
machine cover like I I didn't know what
to do like I yeah and then I asked
somebody else we had a great time like
there's a whole gang of us that went it
was a of course of course yeah at at it
was a better experience than had I just
taken one person by our so it being as
big free-for-all as a
blast